chess grandmaster and twitch streamer
hikaru was temporarily banned from
twitch this week after including dr
disrespect twitch's enemy number one in
one of his streams dr disrespect
recently announced that the legal
disputes between him and twitch had been
settled but clearly something's still
not right here
[Music]
ariel before we get into the video i
gotta remind you as always to the like
button the subscribe button and to ring
the notification bell when you do you
will have my eternal love my heart it is
yours take it
oh i just broke it that wasn't the plan
so if you all have been paying attention
to anything regarding twitch in the past
few years you will remember that dr
disrespect one of the world's biggest
streamers was permanently banned and we
have no idea why can you really ban
doctor disrespect
isn't he the face of twitch there was no
way that they were going to just ban him
out of the blue it would have to be
something pretty catastrophic as far as
i'm concerned
we didn't do anything to warrant a ban
let alone
how they went about banning us it's been
one of twitch's biggest mysteries the
past few years at one point dr
disrespect was one of the biggest faces
on the platform and then one day he was
just gone there have been a lot of
theories as to what happened but to this
day we still don't have any concrete
answers the doc moves streaming to
youtube and has been reunited with old
friends like tim the tatman who recently
made the same switch
it feels so good to hear your voice
twitter's blacklisting of doctor
disrespect has been so severe that
streamers on the platform are not
allowed anything to do with him in fact
it was so bad that twitch allegedly
changed their rules so that streamers
could not even feature suspended
creators like him on their streams we
even reported on call of duty streamers
zealander being barred from a twitch
rivals event for dressing up as dr
disrespect aside from occasional stories
like that we never really heard much
about the dispute until recently where
we got some news on march 10th doc
announced that the ongoing legal dispute
he had with twitch was settled we still
have no idea why he was banned in the
first place but according to doc it is
all over with that said it seems despite
doctor disrespect in twitch allegedly
settling their legal disputes twitch
streamers are still not allowed to
associate with him on stream because
recently chess grandmaster and super
streamer hikaru nakamura was given a ban
of three days for
streaming doctor disrespect playing
chess wait doctor just doctor disrespect
and lupu are playing chess i can be
banned i don't think i can be banned no
hey they want to ban me i mean i'm like
okay so these guys are both pretty new
right
now as many of you know watching and
teaching the biggest streamers how to
play chess is pretty much what hikaru
does it's part of how he became such a
popular streamer dr disrespect was
playing with dr lupo just two ducks
going at it and hikaru was banned for
streaming it you can be banned oh come
on chill out you guys you think i care
come on please i thought all the issues
were resolved by the way with twitch so
whatever who cares i mean they're
playing chess like look twitch wants to
ban me for showing chats like
fine whatever he posted a video on his
youtube channel where he analyzed his
own game and then spoke about his ban
there will be no coverage of the fiat
grand prix on my twitch channel for the
next three days but i i do
just want to stress once again for all
the people out there it is it is
temporary this is not uh permanent and
in any way shape or form and well it's
well it's unfortunate uh it has happened
and again i'm looking forward to
returning twitch it's a bit confusing we
heard the legal dispute between dr
disrespect and twitch had been settled
so
what is going on asthma asmingold
pointed out the apparent inconsistency
when it comes to streaming other band
streamers or even doc himself he said
this seems weird considering dozens of
streamers including me watched both the
ice poseidon and of t-scam controversy
videos and reacted to doc's studio drama
regarding nfts the rules are clearly not
black and white and three days for not
understanding an unstated nuance seems
unfair others disagreed saying that
hikaru clearly violated the terms of
service because doc is still banned in
an interview after a disappointing draw
in the fide grand prix hikaru blamed
some of his inaccuracies on the twitch
situation well i mean i'll i'll i'll be
blunt i mean it has almost nothing to do
with the tournament situation whatsoever
it has to do with everything else that's
happened on the internet over the last
couple of days uh that's been much more
on my mind than um than the tournament
itself so i mean really when you ask me
about the turner how how i feel i'm just
trying to play chess and find some
inspiration because i'm uh there are
other things that are very very
unpleasant and i'm pretty upset about it
but it's all going to be okay because
the doc himself has said that he will be
sending hikaru a bottle of bourbon which
he can enjoy on stream after being
unbanned a day early now i hate bourbon
i'm more of a wine girl myself but i
might be willing to take a shot of
bourbon if i had to deal with a
temporary ban via some weird nuance like
you you have no guarantees and to think
that everything can be ruined over one
one uh one one moment or something that
happens i think is just terrible in my
opinion if twitch wants to make sure
that their high profile streamers don't
stream anything related to one of the
most infamous faces to come from twitch
then tell them make it clear at the end
of the day we may never know why doc was
banned from twitch but up until now it
has caused very strict policy
enforcement which has happened to other
streamers not just hikaru now if you're
like wow twitch is weird with bands it's
because they are multiple creators have
spoken out about the band policy and how
the policy is less of a rule and more
like hey we only apply this when we want
to and that was sort of confirmed when
that alleged do not ban list was
released twitch has failed to protect
their creators from hate raids but thank
god i will never have to worry about
ricegum being banned from the platform
twitch has made moves to make this
process clearer and i guess fairer but
we will see when push comes to shove and
honestly twitch until you start
protecting your creators instead of
punishing them
i'm not super inclined to believe in
your solutions
i can hold up i went chat danny i got a
hat that says wench
that's pretty good isn't that cool i
mean i went to etsy and i was like
custom hats and they're like what do you
want to say and i said wench because
it's always one showers here and it's
wench hours baby
lunch top wench me don't you guys say
top bloke in england i'm a top wench
it's me i'm the top wench i'm the top
branch of the score esports